- [Narrator] Amazon, Ford,
Pepsi, and more from Amazon.
These are just a few of the companies
that have said they were
starting big layoffs
in the last year.
Some job cuts are expected
when the economy hits a rough patch,
but this is different,
not because of the number
of people being laid off,
but because of who.
- We're seeing a really unusual situation
where white-collar
professionals are being laid off
in greater numbers relative
to the rest of the workforce.
- [Narrator] Here's why white-collar jobs
are getting cut first,
and why that's a departure
from slowdowns in the past.
(gentle instrumental music)
Ever since this wave of
job cuts started last year,
experts have said that this
downturn could spell trouble
for professional workers.
- This recession is gonna be really bad,
not only for white-collar workers,
but white Patagonia vested workers.
- [Narrator] But to understand
why those cuts are happening,
we have to go back even further
to the beginning of the pandemic.
As the economy went into crisis mode,
layoffs hit a lot of industries,
but ones that are not
predominantly white-collar
were some of the most affected.
Entertainment, and leisure,
and retail which hire a lot of low wage
and frontline staff made
up most of the job cuts
in the first seven months of 2020.
- In-person workplaces,
everybody got sent home,
and so you had a lot
of white-collar workers
who could do the kinds of jobs
that companies still needed
in great quantity.
And companies like Zoom boomed,
companies like Google and Microsoft,
suddenly their products
were in much greater demand.
- [Narrator] As the
economy started to recover,
some industry saw the average
number of employees grow
from pre-pandemic levels, while others,
especially those with frontline workers,
grew only a little bit or
were left at a deficit.
But as employers are now making job cuts
amid rising interest rates,
they're facing two major problems.
For some, it's an excess
of white-collar workers
who may have been hired
for special projects
or company expansions during the pandemic.
- Some of those projects have
been closed, or pulled back,
or narrowed, and so
companies that hired a lot
during the pandemic are just finding
they don't need as many people.
- [Narrator] But elsewhere,
there's an unmet demand for workers,
namely in blue-collar,
low wage, and frontline jobs.
- It feels like we have
a structural labor shortage
out there where there are,
you know, 4 million fewer people,
a little more than 4 million,
who are in the workforce available to work
than there's demand for workforce.
- [Narrator] The Fed says the
shortage has multiple causes.
Some of it is due to more
people going into retirement,
but other factors like slowing immigration
are also playing a role.
Some economists also say that mindsets
about work have shifted amid
COVID-19 for these workers.
If we look back at that change
in employees on payroll,
some of the industries that have had
a harder time recovering are ones
that a lot of workers didn't return to.
- And companies don't
want to risk being unable
to fill important jobs as
the economy speeds up again.
So they're being careful
about keeping those workers,
some people call it labor hoarding,
they're actually holding
onto these people,
trying to keep them from leaving,
even if they don't need
them all right now.
- [Narrator] As hiring
has started to slow,
ads for jobs in white-collar industries
have fallen the most.
And as for layoffs.
- White-collar workers are
there, they're paid more,
so job cuts can save you
more money with fewer people,
and you don't risk giving up
those hard to find frontline workers
that you're gonna need
when the economy improves.
- [Narrator] But this breaks from the norm
of what has happened in many
other economic slowdowns.
Usually.
- First capital intensive
industries lay people off,
factories and construction companies,
then you see companies with
large low wage workforces,
retailers, hospitality companies,
restaurants and hotels.
And only later, as the
economy really starts to slow
and as a recession looms or kicks in
are professional workers
and white-collar workers usually laid off.
- [Narrator] Just look at the
recession in the early 1980s
where blue-collar workers
made up 75% of layoffs.
- It's few and far between,
jobs are hard to come.
But how about you, you hiring?
- [Narrator] And even
more recently, in 2007,
just before the start
of the great recession,
blue-collar industries like
construction and manufacturing,
were some of the first
to start losing jobs.
By the end of 2008 when mass
layoffs were gaining steam,
industries that are not
predominantly white-collar
were some that had the
most job cut announcements,
that's excluding finance,
which was in a crisis.
- So the classic model we've seen over
the past 38 to 40 years
is that when companies
see a slowdown coming, they shed workers.
They figure, you know,
we can always hire them back
once business picks up again.
But that didn't happen after the pandemic.
- [Narrator] But even
if white-collar workers
are mostly affected by this downturn,
they don't typically
stay unemployed for long.
The majority of tech
workers who were laid off
this year landed a new job
within three months of
starting their search.
- Some smaller companies are
finding it easier to hire now,
because you know, there's
more people on the market.
So just because there's a lot of layoffs
doesn't mean no one's hiring.
- [Narrator] Despite the layoffs,
the job market remains strong
by historical standards.
The Fed is still looking
for it to cool further.
- The economists I've spoken
with expect more layoffs.
They don't expect it to be
like in the financial crisis
when you saw pretty widespread layoffs,
but they do expect layoffs
to spread from, you know,
tech and the white-collar
to other areas where the
economy may slow down next.
- [Narrator] Some
economists say that layoffs
could become more precisely
targeted at underperformers,
as companies try to hold on to
their most valuable employees.
(gentle instrumental music)